l'intention de tolérer
ces campements.
Jérôme Bergeron.
- Avec le printemps, c'est
l'éclosion des campements pour
personnes sans-abri à Montréal.
Des dizaun peu partout
dans la métropole.
- Je m'en vais travailler, moi.
- Près de la rue Notre-Dame,
Alain podélimiter le terrain sul
il a installé son campement
de fortune.
- Je suis ici jusqu'au mois
comme du monde!
- Il a demandé l'anonymat,
craignant les représailles
des autorités. Pour Alain,
pas question de se rendre
- C'est pas ma tasse de thé,
on a rien dans les refuges!
J'ai essayé souvent d'embarquer
dans les programmes,
ça marche pas.
en situation précaire comme
Alain de se trouver un toit,
et le contexte actuelaggrave la.
JOSEFINA BLANCO, responsable
itinérance, comité exécutif Mtl
- Des grands risques d'incen
le pire. C'est pas viable. Nous,
on veut que les get
avoir un toit pour passer
la nuit et que ces personnes-là
puissent avoir accychosocial.
- On va s'en aller ailleurs!
- Jacqueéjà
les expulsions cet été.
- La solution, c'est s'accorder
avec le
- Et demande une plus grande
écoute des différees différees s
de gouvernement, étant incapable
de se trouver un logement
pas de solution
miracle, c'est du logement
tien.
- Le dirigeant de la Mission Old
Brewery dénonce ceille
de Montréal, il réclame à Québec
d'offrir davantage de logeme des
abordables pour aider les gens
à se sortir de la rue.
AMES HUGHES,présidf de
direction, Mission Old Brewery
- Pour accompagner les gens
directement de la es logemenes ,
il faut vraiment miser sur
les solu'itinérance.nistre Lionl
Carmant, responsable du dossier
d'itinérpas retourné
nos demandes d'entrevues.
Radio-Canada, Mon